COV controls the Pucket sets it up up top to
sergachev here St Coast across into the middle
chopped that moved back to Stam Co scores going
to score in the first three seconds the coocher
off play in front of the net to to Paul was
a Miss but then they stayed on it they didn't
pull back they jumped back kept the puck going
and stammer who gets in position knows where
that net is radar just inside the pipe on the
short side outstanding start to the power play
spting forward is chernik back around here is
Sherry getting leaned on by CCE centering pass
comes to fling with a shot rebound they score
the goal scorer's goal execute along the wall
patience stammer gets it to the point nice job
by flurry to get the puck back to the net and
then stammer does what he does knocks this one
right out of the air short side he owns that
short side in this game Skinner can get there and
the lightning of TI it up second goal of the game
for stanos Top Line back out there for Edinson
you'll see a lot of this line there rest of the
way here's stanos now Steven stanos Cuts in brot
doesn't expect it to come when it does because he
stops he's so deep he's in traffic so let's see
if we can get get a look at the golender here
stammer looking him off so Skinner anticipating
something else and you see the stunned look on
Skinner's face afterwards cuz he's thinking okay
he's going to throw to the outside we can't see
Skinner there but I'm willing to bet that he
was taking a glance over to his left to see
who was going to go and look at him here's St
Co St Stan Co he does not miss and it is a four
goal night for Stam Co and the lightning are
going to pull out an extremely gutsy Road win
here tonight stammer with the Magic Touch he was
sick at the beginning of the road trip and boy he
is back to full health now but the battle level
was was really good the confidence level really
started to grow in this third period as they
got down to some basic hockey won some battles
didn't mess around and then got some big plays
the coov goal was a huge one it was a momentum
Turner and that was sheer willpower and in
stammer with his goals terrific St here and
Andre vasileski absolutely a stone wall in the
net John Cooper and the lightning are going to
win this one 74s the final Andre vasileski a star
in net and how about Steven stanos with a four
goal game first time in his career he scored
four goals in a game and what a win this is